ladies and gentlemen we have a new
addition
h portico security specializing cash
trucks across la do you have any idea
how dangerous this job can be
yeah we ain't the predators we're the
prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why am i
pulling pistols in the machine gun fine
do you have a problem
i don't know do i it's a 10 grand drop
you should have been back five minutes
ago
they're serious leave this to me
get in the truck next time sorry pal
who is this lunatic
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
a while back we lost two cars a civilian
too
there was an investigation they still
haven't found a scum who did it
you were in an accident one of my son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
a tree has been shook and it's been
shook hard
we've scorched earth always be a good
boy
you started by saying you do anything
what i'm hearing is
you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job
i can do it in two weeks
you know what i wish you could do in 20
years
when i do bury grudge
[Music]
you